au parc national de la Mauricie on joue
avec le feu depuis 30 ans mais sans se
brûler en fait ça peut paraître
surprenant mais certaines espèces de
plantes et d'arbres ont besoin d'un
incendie de forêt pour se reproduire
c'est pourquoi des scientifiques de par
Canada ont décidé de réintroduire le feu
dans certaines forêts de manière très
contrôlée et vous allez le voir c'est
efficace et spectaculaire
[Musique]
naturelle qui permet de régénérer la
forêt
on réintroduit que les incendies dans le
paysage justement parce que ils ont été
trop supprimés on veut rebalancer cet
écosystème le cycle naturel du feu
aujourd'hui brûlage la Cancale c'est la
deuxième année qu'on va brûler plus dans
le feuillu les années 12 mai 2022 une
réunion importante se déroule ce matin
au parc national de la Mauricie ça c'est
l'unité au complet on va se concentrer
aujourd'hui principalement sur unité 2
une T3 ça fait 30 ans que par Canada
procède à des brûlages dirigés sur ce
territoire de 536 kilomètres carrés
une opération qui est faite de manière
contrôlée on veut contrôler toutes les
paramètres qui sont reliés à ça puis on
a aussi beaucoup de préparations à faire
vous allez voir l'autre côté de la route
qu'on brûle on est dans neige
c'est Serge mon tour qui sera le
commandant d'intervention il va
travailler en coordination avec Philippe
Moisan godet responsable du premier
brûlage dirigé de l'année
au centre des préoccupations la sécurité
de l'équipe on prend notre temps c'est
vraiment pas une course avec la météo
qu'on a on reste allumée à cet art ce
qu'on fait ça vraiment
tranquillement sécuritairement les
radios avec eux Kim Charon Charbonneau
longtemps avant le brûlage son équipe
cible les zones qui seront optimales
pour la régénération de la forêt rien
n'est laissé au hasard
c'est des années de préparation ça prend
une évaluation environnementale qui
permet de s'assurer le qu'on n'a pas des
impacts plus grands que les gains qu'on
va aller chercher ça prend aussi un plan
de brûlage qui est approuvé par
différentes instances justement pour
qu'on puisse passer à l'action ça serait
tout est sécuritaire
vraiment la préparation des derniers
jours on voit que ça a été efficace je
fais beau on a les conditions
normalement tout devrait bien aller
[Musique]
c'est dans le secteur du lac en cœur que
le brûlage printanier aura lieu
[Musique]
se déploie en forêt pour réaliser un
test crucial
juste avant d'allumer on fait notre test
au niveau de la charge de combustible
pour voir si le comportement de feu est
vraiment conforme à ce qu'on a calculé
on allume une petite surface pour voir
comment le feu se comporte s'il brûle
selon les conditions souhaitées
l'opération peut enfin commencer ce
comportement comme on voulait
c'est que ça soit noir partout que ça
brûle complètement
il ne reste qu'un détail à régler il
faut obtenir l'autorisation finale de
parc Canada
Seven Nation
on a allumé une bande de combustible
avec les torches et on va faire des
lignes qui sont plus ou moins
rapprochées donc des lignes d'allumage
ces lignes-là vont venir se rejoindre
avec la direction du vin et vont
vraiment causer une bande de noirs une
bande de combustible qui qui a calciné
dans le fond
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps dans le ciel un des
deux hélicoptères survole les environs
afin d'observer l'évolution du feu mais
ce n'est pas leur seule utilité un autre
va servir à l'allumer
la technique est simple c'est sphère
d'allumage les œufs de dragon seront
projetés en vol dans des secteurs plus
difficiles d'accès ce sont de petites
balles de permanganate de potassium
injecté avec du glycol qui s'enflamment
facilement
l'hélicoptère va venir avec la machine
aérienne faire de l'allumage juste à
proximité d'où est-ce qu'on a allumé
pour venir vraiment noircir tout le
périmètre où est-ce qu'on avait des
opérations
à première vue toutes ces opération peut
sembler un peu paradoxal en quoi mettre
le feu à une forêt petit lettre
bénéfiques pour la nature
[Musique]
on travaille beaucoup sur les écosystème
forestiers au parc national de la
Mauricie un feu va permettre d'aimer la
première couche de matière organique au
sol va permettre une ouverture de
couvert va éliminer la compétition qui
va permettre à ces espèces là qui sont
plus sensibles de pouvoir pousser si on
en est rendu là c'est parce qu'au cours
du dernier siècle les forêts de chêne et
de pain du parc ont subi d'importantes
coupe forestière parallèlement la lutte
contre les feux de forêts est devenue de
plus en plus efficace conséquence le
cycle naturel du feu qui est essentiel à
la régénération des arbres a été
complètement bouleversé le feu
actuellement ne joue plus son rôle
écologique dans l'écosystème forestier
c'est ce qu'on essaie de réintroduire
aujourd'hui
c'est dans un peuplement de feuillus que
l'équipe du parc brûle aujourd'hui elle
veut t'aider à la régénération du chêne
rouge mais aussi réduire la quantité de
matière combustible au sol afin de
limiter les feux de forêt non contrôlés
regardez ça c'est super c'est ce qu'on
veut exactement on avait justement les
arbres parce qu'il faut comprendre ici
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on brûle je
suis souvent besoin d'être rebrulé plus
qu'une fois pour stimuler dans le fond
la repousse et les dragons au niveau des
souches donc on vient vraiment ici le on
va au maximum pour avoir nos gains
écologiques
les zones à brûler ont été choisies en
fonction des routes des lacs et des
cours d'eau qui permettent d'arrêter
naturellement le feu
les pompiers au sol surveillent le
comportement du feu et contrôle son
intensité
ces pompiers là suivent toute
l'opération et leur torche et leur focus
c'est vraiment sur la suppression
de leur mettre d'autres choses
excellent fait que on va arrêter cela
c'est correctile on fait confiance c'est
que
tu peux vous pouvez shutdown puis
démonter votre matériel tranquillement
[Musique]
après des heures de travail intense on
peut enfin dire mission accomplie
c'est hyper content
de la journée c'est toujours des
opérations qui sont quand même
qu'on porte un certain degrés de danger
mais toutes ces fêtes super sécurité par
satisfait de mes équipes
l'équipe du parc va laisser le feu
s'éteindre par lui-même les pompiers
patrouilleront ensuite le secteur durant
quelques jours pour s'assurer qu'il n'y
a plus de danger
[Musique]
le lendemain matin la fumée plane encore
au-dessus des arbres
sur les 536 km² du parc national de la
Mauricie près de 4% ont été restaurés
avec l'aide des brûlages dirigés
[Musique]
c'est le cas du secteur du lac Modène en
2021 par Canada y a réalisé un brûlage
dirigé pour favoriser la régénération
des pins blancs en fait qu'on observe
dans les forêts
majoritaire
mais on n'a aucune régénération ou très
peu en dessous du couvert forestier
est-ce que fait en sorte qu'aujourd'hui
le pain cette fois moins abondant qui
devrait l'être naturellement
le pain blanc est un arbre très
résistant et c'est lui qui profite le
plus des opérations de brûlage dirigées
au parc lors du passage du feu des
espèces qui font compétition au pain
comme le sapin baumier et l'épinettes
sont éliminés mais les hautes branches
et les Corses épaissent des pincements
leur permettent de survivre aux
incendies et de se reproduire la graine
qui tombe au sol si elle a pas les
bonnes conditions pour germer elle
pourra pas se développer les bonnes
conditions c'est avoir une quantité de
lumière suffisante puis un substrat qui
est adéquat c'est vraiment le feu qui
permet c'est d'avoir ces conditions-là
grâce au brûlage dirigé on arrive à
créer de nouveaux habitants qui attirent
les animaux et les plantes adaptées aux
forêts en croissance
un peu plus humide
je pense qu'on a notre arbre
parfait
on va installer l'enregistreur ici en
fait nous aussi on travaille encore à
comprendre tout tous les effets qu'on
les brûlage dirigés d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on dispose des enregistreurs
pour les faire le suivi de la faune puis
la différence entre les sites brûlés non
brûlés
il y a beaucoup d'insectes qui vont
venir profiter de la quantité de bois
mort on constate une augmentation des
populations de pic-bois dans les
secteurs qui sont déjà brûlés justement
parce qu'il y a une abondance de l'art
dans le bois mort puis aussi beaucoup de
d'espèces comme le cerf le lièvre qui
viennent profiter des rejets de souches
puis des nouvelles pousses qui sont dans
le dans le brûlage
la réintroduction du feu au parc porte
fruits mais il faut être patient
en 1995 le parc a réalisé une opération
de brûlage dans le secteur du lac
moucheté à ce moment on y trouvait à
peine 1000 pains à l'hectare depuis on
en compte environ 14000 plus de 3000
pains dépassent 50 cm et quelques
centaines mesure plus de 2 mètres
de faire de créer des forêts qui sont
des zones de forex qui sont un peu plus
jeunes des forêts régénérations ce qu'on
a de moins en moins dans le parc
après 30 ans de brûlage dirigé on
constate les bénéfices mais on sait
aussi qu'il reste encore beaucoup de
travail à faire
je pense qu'on a encore plusieurs années
à travailler pour vraiment le ramener le
feu comme il devrait être normalement
dans l'écosystème si l'humain il serait
pas là on se rapproche toujours de notre
cycle de la feu naturel mais on n'est
pas encore là on a encore on a encore
l'ouvrage
perçu le feu comme un ennemi avec raison
parce qu'il peut avoir un effet assez
destructeur mais pour pour la forêt
c'est un allié c'est un processus
naturel qui est extrêmement important
pour la régénération de nos forêts enfin
qu'il faut faut avoir une vision aussi
qui est positive de ce processus là
[Musique]